madame Olga
je suis tombé mon savon dans le fond
encore ma petite Gervaise vous entendez
mesdemoiselles la vaisselle
c'est ce que nous propose d'imaginer
l'association ELIUM jusqu'au 17
septembre un voyage à travers le temps
est proposé au public pour découvrir les
lavoirs cet équipement d'hygiène
essentielle à l'époque la fonction de ce
travail là c'est interpellé se souvenir
que des lavandières ont travaillé ici ça
a été vivant il y a trois jours il y a
une dame de 87 ans qui est passé et qui
était laveuse dans une dans un séchoir
dans un lavoir de tanneur juste à côté
c'est à la suite des grandes épidémies
et sous l'influence du mouvement
hygiéniste qu'une loi est promulguée en
1851 imposant à chaque commune
l'aménagement de bâtiments spécialement
dédié au lavage une histoire encore
inconnue pour de nombreux visiteurs
de la voir je sais pas d'où vient la
cette histoire mais c'était
au cours et percutant et intéressant
j'ai trouvé que c'était très original
très touchant et l'impression de revivre
le monde des lavandières avec la
participation du réseau patrimoine plus
de 70 la voir de la Vallée de Chevreuse
ont été recensés dont 32 retenus pour
aborder le thème de l'hygiène au 19e
siècle mise en valeur à l'aide de
performance photographies ou encore par
des sculptures il s'agit de rendre un
texte de leur rendre vivant autant que
possible et de restituer ce qui a été ce
que l'auteur ou l'autrice en
l'occurrence il y a beaucoup d'autrices
il y a un auteur quand même a écrit et
bien pouvoir transmettre cette histoire
là est réveillée c'est lavandière comme
ça qui sont au bord de l'eau en sommeil
la balade propose quatre circuits dont
trois dans le département des Yvelines
des balades plus ou moins courtes et
accessibles pour les grands et les
petits jusqu'au 17 septembre
avec les beaux jours en perspective